les 103 agriculteurs menacés d'expulsion
étaient venus accompagn de leur famille
au total 26 tracteurs pour représenter
chacune des fermes touchées par les
mesures d'expropriation le but de cette
opération c'est d'essayer de
sensibiliser le maximum de gens au
problème du Larzac parce qu'on estime
que c'est un problème qui concerne non
seulement les agriculteurs du Larzac non
seulement les gens de laavyon mais aussi
absolument tous les Français c'est pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui nous avons entrepris
de faire une marche à travers toute la
France on espère que sous la pression de
ion finira par se faire se faire
entendre par les gens du gouvernement et
en effet quelques minutes avant le
départ un nouveau contingent de tracteur
venait s'ajouter au précédent il en sera
d'ailleurs ainsi jusqu'à Paris puisque
dans chaque zone rurale les paysans du
Larzac proposeent à leurs collègues de
faire un bout de chemin avec eux samedi
prochain ce sera l'arrivée à Paris Paris
où une motion sera remise au
gouvernement